in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche bella find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape
noise pollution and its effects are our
subject today and my guest in the studio
today is mr michael jackacoopers from
the working group on noise pollution of
the german acoustical society very warm
welcome to in good shape
we're talking about noise for a start
what's the definition of noise
noise is sound which
leads to negative effects on human
beings or on animals and which leads to
impairments and we have different
aspects of those impairments such as
annoyance
loss of performance
diseases health risk
increase
or even financial damage for a person
who has a house near a noisy road
i know people that don't even mind and
excavate digging in front of their own
home and i know people that don't really
like the clock ticking at the wall is
noise a very um
individual thing
the noise sensitivity is indeed
we have a real range of noise
sensitivity and
this depends very much on the individual
as i call it knowledge history of a
person it depends on the
general state
in which a person lives the state of
stress he has and it depends on the
situations where we are in if we
would like to go to sleep nearly every
individual is
very sensitive against noise so the
noise history you mean if i live in a
silent valley and i moved to a big town
a big city then i'm more annoyed by the
noise
on average average right on average and
then it's not only annoying noise can
have bigger major impacts on your health
what sort of problems can it cause
we have two main effects the one effect
is directly concerning the ear
hearing impairment
and this is caused by the
dose of noise we have during our
lifetime
and the other effect
concerns the rest of the body we could
say that means
the risk of heart attacks sleep
disturbances and
even psychic
disorders
the hearing impairment often develops
gradually so so patients don't even know
that they are hearing impaired so what
are the warning signs to look after
if you participate in a conversation in
a restaurant for example you can't
you can understand the people or if you
can't understand the dialogues in a tv
movie
so this is a the thing you should go and
see the doctor for a hearing test yeah
and what about all those other body
problems
not concerning the ear directly there
are a number of diseases which can be
caused by by noise
yes we have the
very important sleep disturbances caused
by the noise during the night where we
are especially sensitive and sleep
disturbances may lead to
diabetes may need to overweight and even
to psychic
disorders such as depressions
and we have the increase of risk for the
cardiovascular
diseases
which is caused by
noise as a stress factor and did you see
a dose dependency the louder the noise
is the more risky it is for developing
diabetes for instance
it depends very much on the of course on
the duration of the exposure uh and we
see this for heart attack risk
increase
seaway also that
it depends on the
if we live very long um along a noisy
road
then the probability to to develop those
how to take risks is higher
what can we do if we can't make the
noise
stop if we look at the environmental
noise we can participate in the noise
abatement plans the
local authorities have to make we can
participate in an initiative
who combats noise
and we have some means of
self-protection for example we can
orientate our sleeping rooms at the
most silent facade of the house we can
close the windows if necessary
and how helpful are soundproof windows
and and curtains or houseplants or some
something you could do in your own
living room or bedroom
sound installation windows are very
effective to reduce the interior noise
levels and curtains and
carpets
can contribute to an increase of the
absorption area and this also leads to a
reduction of the interior noise levels
a lot of sounds we just do to ourselves
voluntarily like plugging mp3 players
into your ears so should i tell my
daughter that she shouldn't heal out
music
i think this is not efficient
but you should explain her how dangerous
the consumption of
earphones and the
visit of discos discourses and that we
need to limit
these consumption of music in these
forms
so so limited in time or limited in
level actually in volume limit in time
and in level because both
aspects are combined to the dose those
effects to the cumulative dose
and for example one can choose a
a disco which has a
certain label
of controlled
loudness
whether this joker is aware of the
problems where the display showing the
noise levels
you can use
earphones or
ipods which are limited in the
volume
that's what you can do and you can limit
your time of course and what about days
of rest so i don't mean sleeping i just
mean going out into nature and in to the
park and hearing no sounds at all that's
an important strategy to to care for in
silent or calm situations and you should
try to find them as
as often as possible okay mr eckel
thanks so much so we all should spend
some time inside and thank you so much
being with us today
you